يتواجد الان في واحده من اكبر المقابر
الجماعيه التي تسببت بها الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هذه المقبره تقع في مدينه
ايزوم التابعه اداريه لمقاطعه خركيف
والقريبه للغايه من محيط الاشتباكات بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه هنا
دفن اكثر من 430 مدنيا قتلهم الجنود الروس
كما تقول المصادر العسكريه الاوكرانيه
المدنيين الذين التقيناهم في المدينه
يقولون انهم خائفون للغايه بل ومرتعبون من
عوده الجنود الروس مره اخرى خاصه بعد ما
نال المدينه من دمار وتخريب وقتل لاكثر من
2000 شخص خلال عام كامل من هذه الحرب
انوي ان اخرج من البيت وفجاه ظهرت احدى
الطائرات الروسيه وقامت باطلاق الرصاص
عشوائيا على المدنيين في الشارع فوقعت على
الارض
وقوعي على الارض من الخوف انقذني هذا
الجسر الذي نقف عليه الان كان جسرا يربط
ما بين مدينه زوم وضواحيها فجرته القوات
الاوكرانيه لمنع وصول التعزيزاته القوات
الروسيه التي كانت تحتل هذه المدينه ولا
يبدو ان ترميما او بناء جديدا لهذا الجسر
عما قريب فالتخوف ما زال قائما من عوده
الروس مره اخرى لهذه المدينه مع قدوم فصل
الربيع وهذا مثال واضح لما مر على هذه
المدينه من اثر الحرب
كنا نعيش رعبا كاملا نظرا للقصف الروسي
المستمر وكنا لا نستطيع التحرك سوى القليل
لا استطيع ان اصدق ان الروس يريدون العوده
مره اخرى ماذا يريدون منا بعد ان دمروا
بلادنا
في سوره مستمره تدوي صافرات الانذار هنا
في سماء مدينه ايزوم بقربها من محيط
الاشتباكات الرعب والخوف يسيطر بصوره
مستمره على المواطنين هنا الذين يقولون ان
هذه الحرب التي دامت لعام كامل شردت
الكثير منهم ويعتمد اطفالهم ودمرت بيوتهم
هنا في هذا المبنى رفع زينسكي بنفسه لعلم
الاوكراني عليه بعد ان نجحت القوات
الاوكرانيه في تحرير هذه المدينه من سيطره
القوات الروسيه سيطره يتخوف المواطنين هنا
ان تفقدها قوات الاوكرانيه بعد عوده
متوقعه للجنود الروس نقلت العربيه والحدث
احمد بجاتو مدينه ايزو